hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm and today was a
special day for all the big chess fans
out there it was this start of the
candidates tournament if you're not too
familiar with the Candace tournament I'm
gonna give you a quick high-level
background on what it is you're gonna
have some of the top eight players in
the world so you have eight players top
three finishers from in this four-tiered
case the chess World Cup in 2011
you have the loser of the 2012 World
Championship you have the next three
top-rated players in the entire world
and then you have a wild card that's you
know nominated for from you know the
Chess Federation they have to be over a
certain rating of 2,700 so they're
they're gonna be a strong Grandmaster
and those eight players play in a
tournament it's usually around two weeks
long it's fourteen rounds and they play
in the winner gets to go on and play
later this year for the world
championship against the current
champion Anan so definitely the exciting
time usually some really really awesome
chess with you know some of the greatest
grandmasters you know in the world right
now as far as the time constraints for
the first 40 moves they get two hours
the next 20 moves they get an hour after
that they have 15 minutes to finish and
then after move 61 they get 30 seconds
per move so in this particular game we
get started as one of the more
anticipated matches the white pieces are
being played by Levon Aronian he's the
number three player in the world
extremely talented grandmaster and then
the black pieces are being played by
Magnus Carlsen the young 22 year old who
is the number one rated chess player in
the world so that's the first match
we're gonna be going over but we're
gonna be going over commentary from a
lot of these matches over the next two
weeks so we'll not only be adding stuff
onto YouTube but we'll be going over the
majority of the games on the website so
definitely make sure you check those out
but this is game number one and so we'll
go ahead and jump right into it
Livan started out with pawn to d4
Carlsen responded Knight f6 white pawn
to c3 and then pawn age 6 and then you
have Knight here to f3 and all the
players is you know especially
high-level play they really don't like
this you know Knight to c3 and then the
bishop coming down here to be for this
is the nimzo-indian defense just gives
black so many different options white
really doesn't have to just doesn't like
to deal with it too
so instead you know a lot of times
you'll see this Knight to f3 instead
makes sense nice strong move trying to
control these dark squares but blacks
are just gonna come down and play Bishop
to b4 this is the Bogle in the in
defense which plays a little bit
differently it now has gives white more
options he doesn't have to play you know
Knight to c3 instead the more common
moves disappeared in d2 and friend even
that was kind of watching this game and
knows a lot about the bow go in the in
defense even early on again we're only
on the fourth move in the game you could
already tell where this game was gonna
go as far as what both sides were really
trying to accomplish because Black has a
lot of different options here you know
the one of the more common moves he has
is Bishop just takes her on D - the
thing with Bishop to d2 though is this
is typically a very draw 'less move so
you know if black were to take here this
usually says hey black is trying to go
ahead and get this to a draw as quick as
possible he would probably accept a draw
right now
if white offered it to him so that's one
option you know again you get half a
point if you draw so it's not always bad
you usually want to get points the whole
point if you're if you're playing the
white pieces but sometimes if you're
playing a really strong player and
you're the black pieces sometimes half a
point is okay but you know black has
other options you could have try to you
know super creative like pawn to to a5
this is always exciting or a very
popular move now is just Queen to e7
again protecting this you know kinking
castle very easily right here on the
Kings side and this is gonna be very
good you know if the bishop takes what
you probably wouldn't right away this
gets a very active Queen early into the
game which is gonna be hard to deal with
for white in the game we saw Magnus
Carlsen take on d2 and again this is not
a bad move by any means but it kind of
lets you know that hey early on this is
round one there's fourteen rounds in
this tournament you have two of the top
players in the entire world happen to
face each other in the first round maybe
they don't want to go blow to blow and
try the most crazy openings of all time
they may just be okay tying this game so
that's what we see from Magnus Carlsen
taken here the
- the Queen's gonna recapture and then
blacks gonna play pawn here to d5 now I
could have you know changed up his move
orders he could have you know castle
down the Kings side but you know it's
all pretty much gonna be the same he's
gonna play pawn here to d5 and then
Knight heater c3 just developing their
minor pieces and then Black's gonna go
ahead and castle on the King side white
now played pawn to e3 makes sense
solidifying this Paul this pawn chain
right here also opening up the door for
his LightSquared Bishop you know again
he still holds a little bit of lead in
development he has you know two of his
Knights developed his LightSquared
Bishop can get involved easily he has
his Queen right here so after he castles
he's gonna have his roots connected
blacks a little bit behind as far as
development he definitely needs to get
some of his pieces involved into the
game next movie plays Queen to e7 so
first move get his Queen involved into
the game and now white brings his rook
over to c1 Black's gonna respond
bringing his rook over to d8 you know
adding more protection here on this this
defy Pawnee now has a pawn his night
here on f6 and also his rook on d8 the
Queen's gonna swing over to C - and then
Black's gonna play pawn here to a6
making sure that you know this Knights
not gonna come here to b5 you know
putting pressure on the c7 square this
would have been again a nice little
outpost for the knight here also
allowing for you know this pawn to push
forward he wants to you know possibly
get this LightSquared Bishop involved
into the game so you know pushing the
pawn for to b5 and then getting the
bishop here - b7 makes a lot of sense
for black white responds with pawn a3
over the course of the game they both
kind of mer each other's moves which to
me is is not the most exciting but you
know that that's just my personal
opinion black now plays Knight here -
these seven basically saying okay I need
to get this knight involved into the
game also kind of blocking off this
light square bishop so more than likely
again he doesn't want to bring you know
bring your Bishop here to d7 is not
gonna do much for you anyway but this
just kind of you know let us know hey
he's probably not gonna be getting his
life too efficient both right now he's
usually gonna be pushing forward you
know b6 or b5 kind of aggressive and
then get his live score Bishop involved
here - b7
white now play Bishop here to e2 and
this is probably the one place where
white did make a mistake you know he was
kind of up as far as his development and
he kind of wasted time here meaning that
you know black just can respond with
taking here on c4 and then after the
bishop takes he just spent two moves
moving his Bishop actually on the next
move he moves his Bishop back so he
moved it three times but there was just
no no need for this right away instead
you know he could have tried something
differently you know he could have just
played you know pawn takes here on
instead of instead of the bishop coming
here to e2 you know he could have played
pawn takes on d5 and then after the pawn
takes on d5 then you know his knight
could have come over here to 2a for
getting ready for you know a nice little
outpost here on c5 also right now
putting pressure on this c7 square so
blacks gonna have to defend with that so
you know after pawn to c6 this is
actually gonna be pretty good for white
you know later on if he can kick this
Knight off he can bring his knight here
to b6
again he can always bring in here to c5
nice little outpost so white definitely
has the advantage in this situation but
after he plays Bishop here to e2 white
kind of gives up all of his you know
initiative that he has and black is able
to equalize you know right away after
taking and then the bishop takes and
then black and just played down you know
pawn here to c5 now you know Carlsen
could have also played pawn to b5 that's
fine as well that probably makes a
little bit more sense
that's kind of what I would have done
but he is higher rated than I am and
he's a lot better chess than I am so he
played pawn to c5 which is completely
fine again just counter attacking the
center of the board and the bishops is
gonna come back here to eat you so it
gives we talked about you know white
just moved his Bishop three times it's
not doing a whole heck of a lot doesn't
really seem to me as I watched this that
he really really wanted to try to go for
the win he seemed pretty content just
playing super conservative
not over-aggressive and then just kind
of hanging back and making sure he
doesn't get in into too crazy of a
situation like now responds with pawn to
b5 again this makes sense he wants to
start putting pressure on the queenside
he also wants to gives light square
bishop vomits of the game it's the one
piece
he doesn't have involved yet pause now
gonna take here on c5 and then the
Queen's going to recapture and then the
pawns gonna come up here to be for both
sides you can tell kind of halves on the
the same layout here they have their
their pawns are the same over here all
their pawns and their Knights are the
same the Queen obviously has to move so
it kicks it back here to e7 Kings gonna
castle here for white definitely needs
to make sure his King is safe and then
the bishops gonna come here to b7 all
moves that make a whole lot of sense
getting all their pieces developed so
both sides now have completed
development here on you know the
sixteenth move is taking a little while
but both sides have complete development
and so now it's trying to time to figure
out okay what are these sides going to
do both of the King sides for both white
and black completely safe it's gonna be
really hard to attack either of the
Queen side if we look at the pawn
structure is exactly the same you know
white right now controls this C file
black controls the D file it's really
hard to say that one can really do too
much you know the minor pieces for both
sides are exactly the same so both sides
are really equal right now someone
doesn't have a whole lot of advantage or
spatial advantage developmental
advantage they are as equal as it gets
right now so white now plays pawn to a4
and then the Queen's just gonna come
down and take on before and after the
pawn recaptures pawns gonna recapture
and then white plays the Queen down here
to b1 now this is another place where
Magnus Carlsen had a few options he
could you know just take it down here on
b1 just trying to exchange off as
material as fast as possible um or he
could say you know what I don't want to
give up my Queen this early I still have
maybe a last attack inside of me with my
queen you know play something like Queen
to e7 you know this is completely fine
he's obviously gonna lose his pawn ease
away you know he already took material
so that's fine he'd still be equal but
still has you know his pieces that he
can fight with in the game he decided
you know again we kind of foreshadowed
this early on but he took here on b1 and
then the roof came over to be one that
would have been a huge mistake if you
know Knight took here on b1 because then
after you know before not only is black
cup of material but he also has a passed
pawn and then all the focus shifts
towards this pawn before you know
fortunately for LaVon he played correct
and he took with his rook here on b1 so
now the bishops gonna come down and take
this Knight and then the bishop is going
to recapture the works gonna swing over
to be a protect this pawn but again
there's too many
you know defenders of this square and
the nice just gonna take here on b5 now
the Knights gonna swing in to be five
more central squared unit wasn't doing
too much on these seven Knights really
reigned supreme if they're in the center
of the board because they can they just
have more squares that they can get to
so again if a knight is you know
anywhere on these four squares to do
really well so centralizing this is
gonna be good for black White's gonna do
the same thing he's got a nice little
outpost for his night right here on d4
and then blacks just okay with with
capturing and then after the knight
recaptures magnus carlsen comes down
takes with his rook swing over take with
your rook here for LaVon and then we
just kind of have a mirror match right
here after the pollen comes to h6 white
responds h3 after this pawn comes down
to g5 we have the same way the g4 Kings
can move g7 King to g2 and then after
the Rick comes down we have a few moves
that kind of mirror each other and then
you see the route come over Knight
outpost here on d4 Knight outpost on d5
and then the rooks gonna swing over to
c2 and again if you look at it it
doesn't take a genius to say these sides
are as equal as you can possibly find so
in this particular scenario both sides
decided to go ahead and call it a draw
for round one so again 31
we reach a equal position and both
decide to go ahead and just chalk it up
as a drawl not to use too much of their
mental energy and then prepare for you
know later matches now these two will
meet in a later round they'll meet in
round number eight and that particular
round magnus carlsen will be playing the
white pieces and LaVon will be defending
with the black pieces so game one to be
honest I was looking forward to it more
than probably anyone besides these
players maybe but wasn't quite what I
was hoping for I was expecting a few
more fireworks but all in all still
excited that this tournaments underway
with some great chess hopefully later on
so hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
hopefully y'all are excited about all
the games for the next two weeks and the
commentary that we're gonna have going
along with it and I will see y'all in
the next video thanks for watching